hey there welcome to Westeros weekly I
am Phillip Molina and joining me Erik
Voss guys Game of Thrones is done
yeah and it's we're a couple weeks after
the finale episode and we are you know
we're gonna have less structured
conversation I think these days about
about Game of Thrones are thinking like
a little loose reel breathe it's about
to get real yeah well we're gonna really
go back through eight seasons of this
thing reflected a series as a whole I
think there was a lot of obsession about
that that last episode and you know hate
it or hate it like I think people are
very focused on that but I think it's
time we start looking backward right at
the series that we did love for years
and years and years and got a lot of
tattoos about yeah I show right yeah
it's it's mm-hmm
it's easy just to focus so much on the
ending of something but really it's the
whole journey and now I've seen some
real angry comments out there saying did
I waste several years of my life for
this though the crow said that
yeah they quit my lie he's gone nothing
to do with any puppeteer in the last
time we did this and I don't know about
you Phillip I refuse to see the past
couple years of my life as a waste of
time here at new rock stars we believe
in gratitude and appreciation for the
cool content that we get for free thanks
to her parents HBO logins send us our
money and I think yeah wait sorry I was
saying that HBO yes I should have not
revealed that we get paid by them well
sure there was some narrative choices we
didn't totally agree with it didn't
resonate with us in the final seasons
it's okay to have mixed emotions about
it but I don't think it is fair for
anyone to say that the people working on
the show are bad writers I think any
great writer is capable of not doing
their best work throughout consistently
throughout their lives but to say that
they're bad writers I think is a Loeb is
too much of a low blow and I thought the
the best way for us right now to go back
and look at the show is to look back
specifically at the scenes that did not
exist in the books that the writers had
to wholly invent for the show
taking the characters at George our
Martin had created in the situation's he
devised but taking them in writing your
best possible fan fiction version of it
of which there are several when you go
back through seasons one through eight
several several moments that surprise
book readers and just casual fans alike
and I think yeah III started writing a
video that I didn't ever finish it was
like 20 pages long and then I was like
will whenever this is unsuitable the
budget was six million dollars released
the philipp cut yeah but in it it was
just kind of explaining why you know the
show left you did that that feeling that
was kind of like I described it as like
the wife of an unsullied on their
wedding night looks like this is nice
there's a key component missing exactly
it was it focused on liking the
characters a lot more than you do in the
books rather than exploring the the
society that is that george RR martin is
built as a reflection of ours and so
characters there behave the way that
they do in social political commentary
mmm-hmm i you know in the stories that
you make a satire piece or something
it's not really about I mean not that
his is satire but in a satire you're
trying to make a point more than you're
trying to develop that character yeah on
TV you need to fall in love with Tyrion
and have them say witty one-liners every
episode so you can sell t-shirts and
stuff right like her it's not really why
but that's the the difference and I
think that a point that I wanted to make
that video and I'll never get around to
was just essentially that there one's
not better than the other but they're so
different that that kind of set
everything on this weird path where is a
very jarring different tone and style
but what I like about what you're saying
is we can acknowledge they're definitely
not better than one better than the
other they're just different
so let's look specifically just at
moments that are from the show there
were actually really great improvements
on story that does not exist in the
books as of yet at least yes and and a
reminder that you can get your Game of
Thrones coverage and updates early by
subscribing to our Westeros weekly
podcast feed and if you're a Marvel fan
we have an Inside Marvel podcast feed
they can get all of your news and
updates soon exclusive content or
podcast feeds coming soon oh yes so more
stuff on this feed coming that's
interesting exciting to talk about but
we'll get to it when you we get to it
moving on to our first show only moment
and you might have seen a preview of it
this is
way back in season 1 episode 5 the wolf
in the line the scene with Robert and
Cersei when they finally get real and be
honest with each other about what their
marriage is so there's an interesting
story behind this we've talked about
this before the season one situation was
these show runners were adapting these
books or specifically book 1 and HBO
came back to them and said your season
is too short you need to shoot and write
more episodes so Dan and Dave are like
okay well what scene what's our dream
scene what's our best fan fiction thing
we can come up with and Robert and
Cersei do not get point-of-view chapters
Robert never gets a point of view
chapter a but in book 1 we never see
them alone when you reading the book so
they basically wrote the best version of
the scene they could imagine this
husband and wife is king and queen
having and it is fantastic it's so
uncomfortable it's like the the dinner
on the office where Jim and Pam go over
and you just see the uncomfortable
relationship these two have yeah well
it's honest and it's vulnerable so this
is the one where like Robert is just
raging about the state of things he's
like that's all the realm is now the
backstabbing the scheming the
ass-licking the money-grubbing sometimes
I don't know what holds it together and
seriously goes our marriage and they
both have a big laugh I think where they
both realize that they're just stuck in
this political sham and they hate each
other but there's there's a truth to
that yeah the they love ass-licking
that's the truth of that way I mean but
who doesn't but also what really reveals
obviously is that they hate each other
but they it's a I don't know where it
lined up year to year but essentially
it's a parallel to to a house of cards
and this idea that our relationship is
political machinations at work and and
maneuvering not the concept of love is
it Joe it's not but also you know
they're a people compare that to
real-life couples a lot of people feel
like their strategic moves a lot of
people felt like Bill and Hillary had
that at certain points in the
relationship where it's man are they
have they been running both for
presidents since you know they met each
other yeah throughout history that's
kind of been the name of the game right
like very rarely especially in these
highborn political
marriage is they're arranged they're
basically set up so that Wars will end
it or Wars will be prevented or Wars
will begin and if george RR martin is an
ardent student of history and that has
been one of the big reasons Game of
Thrones has been so amazing so he's been
able to reflect that one difference from
like the Lord of the Rings where Aragorn
and you know his love at the end it
seems like a true noble love she gives
up her immortality to live with him and
be queen with him forever and it's a
nice romantic view of it but that's not
really how history works you know what's
interesting about this scene also is
that it's not just what we were just
saying about like this loveless thing
they do there still is the pain of not
quite betrayal because you know Lyanna
Mormont
I'm sorry early on a stark I came before
Cersei and in Robert's love life but
there is that jealousy still there and
you can tell that Cersei is kind of like
I guess I was never the one for you
right and she's accepted that but at the
same time you can you can see some
little bit of like pain there
especially considering I mean she's
she's especially in Westeros like the
highest of the highs like you know you
should be so thrilled if you get Cersei
Lannister and he clearly doesn't care
but then there's a really interesting
point that Robert makes where you know
if you think of Leon historic as Helen
of Troy you know the face that launched
a thousand ships yes
she was enough to cause this great chaos
and throw millions of people's lives
into jeopardy and he says he can't
remember what she looks like right which
is so insane that it's it's you know
shows the weight of you know powerful
people and and their love lives and yet
at the same time shows that it's still
just normal people and their love lives
were like you know if you haven't seen
someone in in 10 years or something
maybe it becomes harder and especially
also he didn't have that much time with
her as an adult one right yeah it's it's
it it's reminiscent of like these bar
fights that we've all been in several
times several times yeah where they
start over you know dudes fighting over
a girl but then it just becomes so much
more than that and it's not even about
the girl anymore it's just about the
anger acting yeah it's interesting the
pilot episode at the Dothraki wedding
there's that specific point where the
two Dothraki are fighting over a girl
and then the one who kills the other one
ends up humping a different one
altogether so Daenerys judges that like
oh so the thing they were fighting over
and so in a way Robert as much as he
judges Dothraki as he savages he is in
that same sense the same kind of savage
man who's just angry that his pride was
taken away from him and he's drunken
himself into this stupor now that he
doesn't even remember what he was
fighting over which is such an
interesting character moment and also
like the reason I think that's such a
great scene is Dan and Dave worked in a
lot of like major plot points that would
end up I'm coming later problem yeah
yeah the whole idea of Lyanna stark
obviously she's gonna play a big role
when we find out who John's real mother
is and then Cersei says an interesting
line only a fool would meet the Dothraki
in an open field and Robert's like oh so
I guess you are kind of you think of
yourself as this war tactician and right
battle queen and Robert just kind of
rolls his eyes at it but later in the
series we see Cersei become precisely
that and we see what happens when the
Lannister forces do meet the Dothraki in
an open field again destroyed and also I
mean she's the the daughter of her
father
right exactly who exactly has probably
prepared her just as well as he'd
prepared Jaime yeah speaking of Tywin I
think the next scene that I really loved
in the first season was the introduction
of Tywin Lannister which I don't know
about you I think was one of the best
character introductions and the show I
mean like as an animal lover it was hard
to watch in yet at the same time it was
I normally I cover my eyes and her
crying but in this scenario I was like
so engaged by this actor and I'd never
seen the actor before and I was just
like so he existed to me as all right at
least I hadn't seen the Holly G movie
where he has to dance but but in this
moment I mean I just
it was Tywin Lannister from the books
come to life and it was just so engaging
and I remember this is actually around
the time where I was like oh I'm hooked
on this show yeah I felt the same way
it's the again we don't have
point-of-view chapters from either these
characters in book 1 but this is the
moment
Tywin's blood Elise skinning this deer
while lecturing his son about family
he tells Jamie the lion is not concerned
himself with the opinions of the Sheep
which is just an interesting lana
lannister talking point that they repeat
to each other throughout the series and
it shows time when is this hard-ass
who's not afraid to get his hands bloody
to do what needs to be done to teach his
lesson to his son and what is he doing
he's skinning a stag showing the the
Lannister lion be trail of the Baratheon
stag so it works on so many theme attic
layers and until now we've heard about
Tywin Lannister but we haven't seen him
in action and we've seen Circe we've
seen tyrion we've seen Jaime all three
of these Lannister kids who use their
words effectively whereas we don't we
don't really know who bore them now we
can see the father who is it's willing
to get his hands bloody and be a jerk
and do things like orchestrate the red
wedding but also they are establishing
you know we've seen these these
characters who are in their positions of
power currently but they're still just
children really and ultimately so one
you think that Tyrion is kind of the
most witty character on the show and
even Cersei and Jaime everyone's like
it's so so presented us so they can't be
beat
right and then you meet their dad and
it's like oh all of them are just trying
to get his approval exactly that's what
is motivating you know so we talked
about Liana warm up but this is the the
old disappointed dad face that launched
a thousand this is a like Jamie is the
first time he's super emasculated on the
show up until this moment he's just on
top of the world he's cocky he's he
pushes a kid out the window and he gets
away with all of it but this is kind of
like the kid who bullies you in school
seeing his dad pick him up in his truck
in the parking lot and you to see his
dad like yelling at him in the car and
your bully starts crying and yeah
satisfying and fascinating to watch he
started to feel bad for your bully for a
second yeah you're like I'm hooked on
this story now yeah so ultimately we see
Jamie the Kingslayer stuck in his
father's shadow and you see the the
layers of daddy issues that happen in
the team Lannister that motivate these
characters and seasons to come
yeah there's so another
one of my favorite moments from the show
that is not in the books is another
Tywin moment there actually and it's
just the those conversations that he has
with Arya oh yeah yeah are fascinating
these are those were again some of the
best best written show only moments like
specifically the writing I mean I the
little dance that they're playing with
the other where to this day you go back
and you watch it and you know that Tywin
knows that she has a secret right that's
our next big moment it's in season 2 or
episode 7 it's a whole season later yeah
and what's interesting is that it's sort
of in the books Arya serves Roose Bolton
but in the show they're just like oh
let's put the guy who is commanding the
forces against Aria's brother Robb as
the guy that she serves like what great
dramatic irony because she's listening
into the movement of the Lannister
forces and Rob's victories on the
battlefield he can Tywin is so smart and
that's what's great about watching
earlier seasons is all the characters
are at the top of their intelligence
it's just great to see smart characters
be smart and out thank each other and
not say everything that's on their mind
like there's layers of subtext and just
the way that anytime people in war
scenarios and political conspiracies
talk to each other there's subtext
there's layers of meaning to what they
say and they only say what they need to
say and in this these interactions with
Aria and Tywin yeah as you said Tywin it
seems like knows that there's a deeper
secret to this servant girl in fact he's
one of the few people recognize that
she's a girl at all like everyone else
just right sir her her grammar her
that's right believe lowly born grammar
but he also you know he's clearly I mean
if anyone was like kind of playing the
game of Thrones almost effortlessly it
was Tywin Lannister at that time and
it's all those we would watch
Littlefinger back in his early season
really that guy is always up to
something else right but the fact that
we could pick up on that kind of shows
like well maybe he wasn't amazing at it
actually
but Tywin I loved in the this early
scene where they meet we looking back
now or realizing oh he was making those
kinds of moves where he offers her food
from his plate and we now realize Oh
kind of like humanized him at the time
he was worried about being poisoned
people had been making threats on his
life and trying to kill him and then
here's some lowly person who clearly
also is up to something
it's like well you know if this boy dies
nothing nothing's loss and if the boy
lives I look really nice as an old man
that gave you food
yeah and they you see arias restraint
and her patience in this moment because
she gets a knife to cut mutton with and
the camera pushes in on Tywin's neck as
he's looking out the window
and she almost goes for it and then she
holds back because she knows that
there's no way she would survive or
should get out of Harrenhal alive if she
did that so she for the first time
exercises patience she has power but she
decides not to act on it in all the
while Tywin is lecturing her about
history about famous Lords the past
about war about legacy she learns about
the Lord Harun who built Harrenhal
callously assuming that he'd be safe
from dragon fire inside this castle
without thinking that Dragons can
breathe fire or fly over him and cook
him alive in his caste and turn into a
ruin
so Arya is learning about all these
things and about the importance of what
you leave behind and these are kind of
lessons that you see her apply later in
the series this is a big adult moment
for her she gets the father figure that
she lost from Ned and Tywin gets a
daughter figure that he lost from Cersei
growing older and becoming two rival to
him and this was also from a time when
everything was so efficient right like
the what if you were watching what's
happening in the scene listening to
dialogue a lot is happening at the same
time yeah are you called out that it's
mutton that he's eating mutton is the
flesh of a matured sheep which is a nice
like connection if you if you understand
when Tywin says something like the lines
not concern himself with the Sheep he's
like yeah literally like that's all I
eat the thing you I eat every day is
what you're bringing to me right yeah so
it's a great moment and we never really
get full confirmation on how much Tywin
new he knew that she was masquerading he
says it's milord if you want to pretend
to be lowborn you say my lord not my
lord that's what highborn kids say and
he knows that she can read too cuz he
sees her reading maps so it's
interesting that he never acts on
and it kind of remains a mystery how
much you know you have to assume if he
knew that she was Arya Stark he would
have oh yeah he would use her absolutely
but let's move on to another moment that
is great when Yuri watched his series
it's the moment where Catelyn confesses
her guilt over Jon and she's talking to
Tulisa
now in the books Catelyn hates Jon just
like she hates him on the show but
Michelle Fairley as actress brought so
much humanity to that character so the
writers wrote this really emotional
confession for her in which she talks -
Talisa Rob's new wife and another
character has a lot more to do in the
show than the counterpart character does
in the books but Catelyn cell tells her
that when Jon was a baby she prayed to
the gods for him to die because she
hated him so much jon was a symbol of
who hasn't yeah I mean that it's 3:00
a.m. that baby's still crying yeah you
know the so Jon came down with a fever
as a baby and he almost did die and then
Catelyn felt so much guilt that she
prayed to the gods again begging them to
let the boy live and she promised that
if John were to recover she would raise
him as her own son and then once the boy
did recover she's like I'm just kidding
she continued to treat him horribly and
now she believes that all the horror
that befell her family was her fault she
said this is all because I couldn't love
a motherless child right it's like an
insult to the mother yes God but yeah
that's something that the matriarch role
often struggles with and in these kinds
of stories is anything that befall is
the family we think of the the soldier
the warrior as the defender of the
family but the matriarch in these
stories often feels like it's actually
at the end of the day the last line of
defense is the mother and if you think
of it from the animal kingdom right it's
like you know stay away from a mama cat
or a mama boss like they're very
dangerous oh yeah and what's cool here
in this moment she's weaving the thing
that people who pray to the mother weave
it's just to the gods to the seven gods
this kind of Prayer thing she was
weaving it when bran was sick to kind of
pray for his recovery and it was just
this nice little bit of world-building
from the show the religions of Westeros
are fascinating destroyed Ramona's
created them I mean you're
yeah oh yeah yeah I keep jumping back
and forth between the faith and the
Zoroastrianism yeah
but the it was just a nice little piece
of this culture that in later seasons
the show just kind of departed from
because it was no longer serving the
plot and the story that they needed to
tell but man I and maybe they felt that
they kind of gassed out on everything
religion wise in season five and six
with the faith in the high Sparrow
in King's Landing but I loved the little
wing set people praying at weirwood
trees the fact that John would go pray
at the weirwood tree and to his vows
there instead of in the Sept in Castle
black because he was raised differently
and he identified with his father's
religion there's all these little things
that feel so real and authentic and this
is an example of that just like little
plot things like what are the characters
doing with their hands and I feel like
in season seven and eight there's a lot
of characters just standing in rooms
with like brilliant framing and
beautiful sets but like you don't
understand like what they're physically
doing in that moment I don't necessarily
feel like real people they feel like
actors on a stage yeah something I liked
about the story about Jon and the fever
is that it sets up something that not at
this point but but later we start to see
John is somehow the most tested and yet
the most lucky survivor he's been born
with that plot oh yeah yeah yeah exactly
but it is almost like it makes you
wonder is he destined to to be tortured
and always be in peril or is he destined
to no matter what always survived the
day right yeah he has it makes me wonder
about his mortality at all of course he
died on the show but was resurrected did
the gods or did the Lord of Light always
intend on this boy being a hurt and
survivor to play some greater role so
this is again was not something the
books we didn't know that baby Jon had a
fever and the books but the show kind of
imbued him with this treatment yeah Siva
and yeah it definitely sets him up as
this new hero but it also gives Catelyn
a moment of humanity this is maybe six
episodes before she gets killed at the
red wedding so in a way it's kind of
like a person on death row giving a
confession before
you know they died so it was a nice
moment that humanized her character and
and you can see maybe her death as a
punishment for a lifetime of torment
john-boy definitely for her probably
some of her final thoughts are I was
right because she looks around her and
her entire family is being slaughtered
and she's like you know just because I
couldn't love John like it's exactly
what her worst fear was solutely before
we continue we want to thank expressvpn
for helping us make this episode
admit it you think that cybercrime is
something that happens to other people
right you may think that no one wants
your data or that hackers can't grab
your passwords or credit card details
but you'd be wrong it happened to you it
happened to me happens to a lot of you I
assumed stealing data from unsuspecting
people on public Wi-Fi is one of the
simplest and cheapest ways for hackers
to make money and when you leave your
internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your password
some credit card information on a huge
billboard for the rest of the world to
see that's why we decided to take action
to protect myself from cyber criminals I
use Express VPN expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address expressvpn is easy to
use apps that run seamlessly in the
background of your computer phone or
tablet
turning on expressvpn protection only
takes one click using expressvpn I can
safely surf on public Wi-Fi without
being snooped on or having my personal
data stolen for less than seven dollars
a month you can get the same expressvpn
protection that I have expressvpn is
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar and comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee protect your online
activity today and find out how you can
get three months free at expressvpn comm
slash rock stars
that's exp ress VPN comm slash rock
stars for three months free with one
year package visit expressvpn dot-com
slash rock stars to learn more now you
just gotta stop leaving your Facebook
open I know I refused oh you enjoy what
I do too
yes yeah I'm asking for this let's talk
about a next moment that it was from the
show and and or early s'more important
in this show and that's just the I mean
it resolved it has this famous quote in
it but it's a little finger embarrassing
where he reveals essentially his thesis
or his most operate
some chaos is a ladder yes and and you
know didn't seem like when we were
watching this in season three was
episode 6 that these one of these two
characters might win the Iron Throne
it's these two background political
conspirators who are in the literal
shadow of the Iron Throne gazing at it
longing for it and for this moment they
seem like by far the smartest characters
in Westeros because you realize at this
point that Littlefinger is a mastermind
behind the war of the five kings and we
know from the books that Varys is kind
of the mastermind behind the dance of
dragons and we know that in season one
he was trying to get Daenerys
assassinated and then he started to
plant the seeds of maybe I could use
Daenerys to retake the Iron Throne which
he does in season five so we're kind of
wondering in the endgame at this point
which of these two geniuses will take
the Iron Throne despite neither of them
having important names or neither of
them seeming like good enough candidates
but just by their their wits and their
skills and their determination alone
might be the one to take it and they
open up a lot of interesting points
about politics and the nature of
conflict on this yeah it's like their
campaign managers having a kind of off
the record meeting in the background I
think that it it makes me long for well
it made me long for moments like this
later when in the final season we see
that Tyrion who tiering kind of adopts a
bit of this role to kind of I'm you know
at least he's the front-facing campaign
manager twofer for Daenerys I when we
see that Tyrion and Varys are on the
same side that kind of like bummed me
out a little bit at the end there
because I was missing this right the two
great masterminds on opposing sides and
you know having different goals in the
books there's a different potential heir
to the throne an additional potential
heir to the throne and so the idea that
if that had been included in the show
maybe Varys would have been trying to
make his moves to support that character
Tyrion is trying to support the nares
and then we have this very complex I
struggle for the throne but the
political side of it which you know we
went through the night Kings story and
we kind of knew something
gonna happen with the throne part but it
kind of fell together and there was a
lot of you know she is my queen one
queen I kind of stuff instead of really
good debate about well it should it be
this person or should it be this person
yeah is that janja saying well no I
don't want it to be me yeah I this is a
scene that I go re-watch probably once a
year because it just reminds me of a
time on Game of Thrones were people
again we're just smart like seeing two
smart people talk to each other they're
these two people playing like verbal
chess you know and you're kind of
wondering what's really going on under
in the subtext of these characters and
it brings up this fascinating point
about chaos which is something that
exists throughout the show Game of
Thrones is something that it always
subverts our expectations and these two
people are pondering on that subject
Littlefinger believes that chaos is a
ladder it's a positive thing it's a
chance for opportunity for people
otherwise wouldn't get it whereas
various only sees chaos as a destructive
force when things don't go according to
plan
the innocent people die so it's kind of
these dueling philosophies that make us
wonder do we love the unpredictable
bloody nature of Game of Thrones or is
this something that is reckless and
irresponsible because it it kind of is
this kind of Joker mindset where do we
want to see the world burn is it fun but
is it responsible well and you don't
have to agree with either of them but in
terms of what you think you should do or
one should do but they're both right
what they're both describing is the Wild
West yeah and the Wild West is that
people use it as a metaphor to mean you
know it's crazy there's there's no rules
but also you could get rich absolutely
which is the idea that works for both of
them people will die it's a Wild West
and you will get rich if you survive
yeah so season 3 ends with the red
wedding obviously everyone kind of
agrees is one of the best sequences on
the show but we knew it was gonna happen
in the book so let's move on to a moment
that was not in the books at the start
of season 4 this is just a moment with
Arya and the Hound when they're in the
end and it's just a nice small little
moment with great dialogue and remember
it's starting I think we were watching
in that first episode of season 4 and
we're like this is just so great now
Arya does get like a vengeful moment
where she murders a guy in the books but
they put it in a new setting
specifically where she she runs an
Apollo her she
needle back she avenges la me and there
in this great moment where they're
watching the innkeeper and his daughter
get taken advantage of and the hound
establishes his famous love of chicken
right and he brings up eating chicken
it's like eight times in the scene and
it's just it's funny it's there's so
much great dramatic irony and there's
just several the Hound doesn't even want
to be here it was Arya who dragged him
in there because she recognized polliver
and it's just a great moment that
fortifies their friendship so she's less
of a captive now and more of an equal
and a partner and and this is the
glimpse of Arya the real Arya or Lisi
Aria she becomes if you go compare her
acting and in the character in the last
season to this scene you'll see she does
this stare yeah there's this you know
stare they're like is seen all the
places needle can go through you right
right yeah I and it starts right here in
this moment except you know so many
years earlier and we play it in totally
process how far down that path should go
but you know it was it was there from
the beginning yeah this is the episode
it was titled two swords in an open with
Tywin melting down that Starks Valyrian
steel sword into the two that he gave to
Joffrey and to Jaime but really there
were other swords in the scene and
really the reacquisition of needle was
such an important moment arguably more
important than the other titular two
swords the way that she uses needle just
just like a little poke in the eye to me
also was this understanding that Arya
and this moment realizes the rules are
both and this is how easy it is to take
someone's life yeah look I just made
that motion and now that person's not
gonna be here in a moment I never bench
somebody you know like yeah it is this
this she is creating a whole new world
order inside of her head
this is how my world can work I can walk
up to someone poco
you know poke a hole in them and then
they're done yeah from here we move on
to one of the most shocking moments on
the show probably the first moment that
surprised both book readers and fans
alike is at this point a book readers
had seen the occasional like
conversation scene that was fun that
they didn't know what happened
this is the scene that changed the
nature of the show and the game as a
whole so this was Season four Episode
four oathkeepers that suddenly ended
with the shot of Craster's baby being
taken by the white walkers and we follow
them far far up north further than the
books had ever gone and we meet who ends
up getting revealed as the night king
and we see what their whole objective is
is to take babies and transform them
into new young white walkers and we
learned so much about the white walkers
in this moment but it's really just a
great mystery box is that because it
creates so many questions they have a
culture now they're they're lined up in
this almost it's like a ceremonial
pattern they have what looks like an ice
altar there's like a weird spirituality
to this rather than just being these in
shadow ice demons that are very hard to
kill and somehow undead we now it looks
like they have a culture and a society
and a home that's more than the book
readers ever knew about the White
Walkers and this is a good example of
why we both defend the writers of the
show not because we think they're
flawless because I mean I don't think
I've ever read anything from a writer
that didn't have flaws it's these little
adjustments that make them that show
their understanding of storytelling so
to introduce a scene like this you refer
to it as a mystery box I refer to it as
question tool they use this moment of
mystery or question to get you through
exposition and the political chaos and
you know we're on the other side of the
red wedding so it's it's not even it's
it was in a point in the show where we
we initially thought we were gonna
follow a Ned Stark and we're like oh my
god he died I guess we'll follow Rob
stark
oh my god he dies and we haven't really
established our new protagonist fully we
don't mean it's a while before John is
you know really that relevant so in this
moment that's them realizing I don't
want to say it's a flaw necessarily in
George's story because again the books
it's so such a different style of
storytelling but they're acknowledging
in this moment in the greater story the
audience is no
longer as invested as they were pre-read
wedding it actually the red wedding is
such a great moment but actually is a
very hard thing to right after yeah
before something else huge huge happens
so the insert a scene that gives you
this huge question and it's it now
provides gasoline for you to kind of
have that in the background and now you
can get through some more shaking up the
probably one of the most famous examples
for me of this is the opening to the
Breaking Bad pilot
oh yeah it starts with just insane chaos
you have so many questions and then it
goes to the most boring story you can
ever imagine it's a middle school
science teacher just going through his
day and it does have like 20 minutes but
it earned the 20 minutes by just
starting with the chaos same thing this
earns like episodes and episodes of just
slight political maneuverings yeah and I
think this is the moment that got people
like us invested in Game of Thrones to
make videos because from here on out
word we had so much crazy online
theories stemming from this moment about
how the White Walkers because now the
White Walkers moved from a background
lingering existential threat on the show
to active antagonists that might play an
even greater role in this series as it
moves on and we'll talk about later how
that changed our expectations and Game
of Thrones because the the rest of
season for the bulk of season 5 kind of
hit like a stalling point because George
RR Martin's plots and the book started
to hit a bit of a stalling point you
know a lot of the characters kind of
reached what seemed like their goals but
didn't have a whole lot to do I assume
in the next two books that he'll make
pivots again but the writers weren't
really sure exactly where he was going
with those storylines but this happened
they finally made a big bold decision at
the end of season five with the hardhome
episode which saw was a step forward
from the Craster's baby to the knight
king introducing himself to the world as
this new villain that is going to be an
immediate threat to Jon and now to be
clear the hardhome incident happens in
the world of the books it's mentioned
but we don't see a chapter from with
someone's point of view seeing that
happen so book readers knew once we saw
that episode title was hardhome
that something bad what's gonna happen
there but as it unfolded in front of our
eyes I think we're all shocked by the
disaster of work and it this is another
brilliant move honestly and it's one of
the things that TV does really well he
did centralize the conflict into an
individual yes and it gave us someone to
fear instead of a general presence right
like a lot of people talk about the
shark in Jaws being so it was like well
we didn't need to see him so much like
yeah but can you imagine if all we saw
was multiple shark fins throughout the
movie it would be unsent relized yes and
so to give us this focus it actually
made it a more direct threat so I mean
that I remember having this thought way
back when when I was so I was so
unsettled when in the previous moment we
talked about when Craster's baby gets
converted and then in this moment we see
it on mass the idea of the blue eye
change and I remember finding it
unsettling for like in a different way
and a long time later I was just writing
something history related and I realized
that way back when I first saw this it I
subconsciously I was thinking of the
Nazi experiments where is this concept
they used to try to make eyes blue and
it was literally like with like acid
yeah the whole eugenics that they would
try to try out a cliche of trying to
convert who's already there in - you
know his master race day and these
blue-eyed light-skinned very
light-skinned white walkers I obviously
you know there's already someone typed
in a comment about like that's a stretch
but I do think that there is this
unsettling thing of taking what we
already are and converting it into what
you think we should be which I think it
was just like there we don't know
exactly I mean the the blue eyes is
something that is established previously
and I don't think that it was done
purposely but I think that deep down
especially dark features people were
very scary of the blue eyes like you
well everyone with blue eyes is a
murderous soulless drone I think that's
a given
but I see what you're saying and I think
the horror of this moment
is is unparalleled the way support Nick
shot this sequence just with the
simplicity of the dead people's eyes
flicking open silently it felt like a
kind of a zombie feel and this is a
moment where I feel like Game of Thrones
pivoted from something where the writing
was in control to something where the
directing took the drivers wheel because
from this moment onward it seemed like
the writers were writing to gifted
directors like Stepanek to deliver the
biggest most fascinating spectacle HBO
was pouring money into the show at this
point so everything that happens after
hardhome including heart home feels more
like building up toward big spectacle
big epic battle moments with a lot of
extras and a lot of CGI yeah and
obviously directing is a role that
doesn't exist in books right it's uh
it's the writers medium television
actually is often described as a
writer's medium but that actually I'm
glad you brought that up the idea of the
importance of directing not this moment
but another miguel symphonic battle is
the Battle of the bastards that episode
is so good
go watch that up again you can watch it
on mute and you're blown away but you
can watch it on mute
yeah and what I mean by that is that
it's not really the writing that's
blowing you away
Miguel's watch Nick is referencing the
great war films one and we'll talk about
that all the bastards in a second that's
kind of transition there for a second
but my point there is that there was a
weird and I just fell off the Raven he's
given up i I think that Miguel's upon
Schneck showed us look how good I can
make this in spite of some awkward
writing so as we go through the battle
bastards you if you do rewatch it you
have to admit that there are some dumb
choices made that Jon Snow is he he
tries to attack all the men by himself
basically and then that's also the one
where the Knights of the Vale come in
they saved the day but it actually is
kind of a another one of these moments
where I was like I don't know if that
made me feel great about our characters
were like these other characters came
out of nowhere and why didn't sense it
tell them I mean it's bad
strategy why would you not say I have
people coming up the rear that help so
has all the a lot of actually
uncomfortable moments even though it's
one of my favorite episodes but it's
because it's one of the best directed
episodes yeah and we kind of see that
trend going on in this season six so I
think one of the impressive moments with
the writing of season six and two before
the ending was the whole arc with the
Tower of joy this is a moment that book
readers had wanted to see one of the
famous past moments so I think it was a
wise move for the writers to dramatize
that show a young Ned Stark show the
fear of him in that moment because we
always remembered it as a story that
bran would tell and other people around
the continent would tell about how Ned
Stark was able to defeat Sir Arthur
Dayne
whereas Ned would remind brandies like
the only reason I was able to do that
because Helen read and we see an MMO
where Nets about to be killed and we
feel scared because even though we know
Ned's gonna live on we feel that he's
gonna die in that moment Helen Reid
stabs him through the chest but really
what's impressive about the Tower of joy
is the way they kind of structured the
reveal of Jon Snow's true lineage which
is something that many book readers who
kind of speculated would be the case but
that reveal was so emotionally and
dramatically done and it was just super
satisfying to see the show decide to
stay true to that storyline because they
don't have to use all these things I
just think it was impressive that by
revealing John as the son of Rhaegar and
Lyanna gives this orphan a victory yeah
as someone who is long-suffering on a
show believing he's a bastard but
specifically what's brilliant about it
is they tell us the truth about Jon
seasons before Jon ever learns about it
and what's best about John is he's a
character who knows nothing he's more
interesting to watch when he's kind of
left out of the loop so they cut from
baby Jon to real Jon do to tell us the
truth about him but we we never have to
worry about him knowing because it's
it's not as fun when he knows and
honestly when I think it's also a little
partially like once Jon knows I'm sure
the writers were a little bit George
didn't really tell us much about John's
reaction to it so I think that is one of
the reasons why it gets pushed very late
and if you do look back at the last
season that probably is one of the flaws
like
knowledge all right is it feels as if
John finding out ultimately doesn't
matter right I think that will go
differently in the books I'll be
interesting now before we continue we
also want to thank Mack Weldon for
helping us make this episode Mack Weldon
makes smartly designed men's clothing
and their user experience is super easy
and convenient
they made their name with men's
underwear and they have some really cool
ones that have silver sewn into them
that makes them naturally antimicrobial
and yeah they smell better yeah which is
great for underwear and Mac Weldon has
expanded beyond underwear and have all
kinds of men's clothing like sweatshirts
hats swim trunks all kinds of stuff I
just ordered some of their t-shirts
because I like the colors and they had
16 to pick from the website was easy to
use and the whole process was super
convenient I also got some of those
silver underwear because you know I'm
just I'm excited to try them out and you
know apply some scientific method to my
team I was a microbiology major and this
is the only way I use it for 20% off
your first order head to Mac Weldon comm
and enter the promo code westeros at
checkout again that's promo code
westeros at Mack Weldon comm for 20% off
your first order now I want to move on
to later in season six this was we were
talking about this to battle the
bastards now this was something not in
the books it's a plot point that John
seemed to be headed toward before the
its Nights Watch mutineers took him out
but there was a whole idea with a pink
letter where Ramsay Bolton was baiting
him to come back and reclaim his
family's home now Phillip you're
bringing up some some interesting points
before about how the the writing seemed
a little convenient to to set up these
spectacles what I liked about this is
it's not always easy to deliver
effective payoff to see what characters
get what they deserve and this happened
both for the victors and the defeated in
this battle to see Sansa be the one to
stick the dogs on Ramsay to put him to
death was a very satisfying feeling an
important moment for Sansa yes to see
Jon tackle Ramsay and beat the crap out
of him to see Ramsay specifically use
arrows throughout this battle as his
primary weapon earlier in the series we
had seen him practicing on the flayed
man
people out before the Winterfell grounds
so uses it to kill Rickon and he uses it
against one one and he uses it against
John in that final charge in the
Winterfell courtyard I thought there was
some really smart choices made both by
the writers and the director of that
episode to make that the most effective
payoff and I think in the finale of
season six this is kind of the finale
that I think this is if the show had
ended at the end of season six yes there
would have been some questions people
still had but I think people would have
been satisfied with this show this is I
mean despite row saying about the
writing actually this is my favorite
movie in Game of Thrones that's really
what it was I had its own arc its own
story it's kind of its own twist and
Dean and all of that and you know it is
so self-contained and done so well but
again it I feel like that's this is when
I fell in love with my girls ' yeah and
now we're getting married so look at me
Hank yeah no but it was I just was
watching this I was like why do I feel
it so much you know we had the series up
to this point we had fallen in love with
the dialogue very much a lot of that was
the mastery of george RR martin and his
dialogue but later when I talk about
this show I've often said some of the
best creators and filmmakers in the
world are working on it
this is who I mean I mean Miguel so posh
Nick and if you I mean you can go I did
a breakdown of this episode actually
where I really get into the directing
and cinematography techniques he's using
in order for us to feel it but
specifically there's that famous moment
where John is overtaken by a sea of
people and he basically drowns within
them and it also was very reminiscent of
there was that shot of Daenerys
Targaryen so it had where she was
surrounded by her as well the nice man
had the the nice parallel like these
people are on somewhere past and yes
eventually I did cross but actually just
in the directing of it you can I
remember you there's I believe there was
like a heartbeat that you could hear
there and then you also had these shots
it was all designed in a way to make you
feel like you were drowning yeah and I
felt it with this and I thought about in
Blade Runner 2049 oh yeah there's a
great moment there were you in your seat
start feeling like you're drowning and
this is when I was like oh man this guy
is so good that this is probably
now that is done honestly still one of
my favorite episodes and it's still yet
separate from the writing of the episode
and speaking of Miguel's appachan I
think we can agree maybe his best
direction on the show came in the
following episode the season 6 finale
the winds of winter when Cersei blew up
the Sept so in my opinion this is the
best sequence of the series first 20 in
the first 20 minutes yeah it's so well
written directed edited the music is
brilliant this is the first time Miguel
Ramin Djawadi used piano and a score on
the show to show the shifting feel the
winds of winter changing it's a new
season yeah and though the way this
scene the sequence was shot for 20
minutes however long it lasts each of
the characters begins privately in their
room getting dressed for their day and
he realized that they're prepping for
their funerals the way he shot them
makes it look like clothes being put on
a body by a mortician
so it's also Stefanik trademark shot too
he opens most of his episodes with the
small choices the people are made up to
that are gonna be part of this huge epic
event so this is a perfect example of
foreshadowing on the show they gave us
just enough information to make us think
that something like this could happen
but also make us feel surprised when it
did happen because of course wildfire
was teased the first firework at the
Battle of Blackwater but then throughout
the show there was just little bits of
dialogue where characters were like well
of course the Mad King did put wildfire
all over the city do you remember this
such a small choice and this was like
the show's being so subtle and we're
still such [ __ ] for scrutinizing
every frame so much that we still picked
up on this I there's a shot that's
panning through I believe the Red Keep
and the camera is swinging vertically
and it crosses across the ground and on
the floor you see a sewer grate and
they're kind of just holds for a second
and then keeps going and we're like that
means that there's a wildfire Beneatha
in the like sewers essentially it's
gonna like we had so much based on just
that ideas remind you that there were
tunnels hints of green started to get
yeah yeah absolutely so this is another
example of a moment that if this were
the finale of the show I think it would
have been okay because Circe's story
essentially ends here once she becomes
the
and she gets the throne Tommen has
committed suicide you know so that
fulfills her prophecy she gets what she
wants but she becomes the ultimate
villain of the show and everything that
happened afterwards with Cersei was just
not as interesting in my opinion so if
the series had ended or if this had been
somehow if he could restructure things
to make this happen in the final season
I would have been okay with this yeah
this is the first time that we see her
staring out that window sipping her wine
and it feels so delicious in that moment
her victory and then she never leaves
that spot I can't I believe like for the
rest of the series she's basically like
you know what how about I only do my
scenes in this window here right now
moving on to season seven of course the
the wall being collapsed by bazarian was
fascinating but that's something that I
feel was all spectacle not a ton of
writing going on but in at the end of
season six arya kills Walder Frey and
season seven begins with what I think
was like the last moment I really just
devoured the writing of this moment
which is when she gets revenge on the
phrase by taking Walder Frey's face and
wearing it and when scene something
begins with Walder Frey we're like whoa
is this a flashback like what is going
on but we get to see Arya get revenge
against the phrase and kind of replay
the red wedding the way that Cersei got
revenge against the faith by blowing up
the Sept kind of revenge for her walk of
shame moment Arya gets her revenge for
her walk of shame by cueing the phrase
and giving this wonderful monologue that
we get to see delivered by this actor
who's like one of the best character
actors ever on the show talking about
how you should have ripped out all the
Wolves root and stem and if you leave
one lone wolf they'll come back and get
you and it's just this fascinating
reveal as they're drinking the wine they
get poisoned and then she walks out but
I don't know how you felt about this to
me this felt like this it almost was to
show jumping the shark after this whoa
after right this moment was very
necessary and I think it's actually one
of the successful realignments between
the story in the books and the story in
the show because this is something that
Lady Stoneheart
like it would have done or and this this
taking vengeance on the on the red
wedding is basically the character's
purpose
so giving that to aria actually I
thought was a great choice it was the
character that we wanted to see and and
we needed to see start going down that
path if she was gonna become ruthless
also all in retrospect now we can see
this is the moment that we get Arya's
faceless man capability yes it actually
is really even though she's used in
other ways she's a mayor trend well this
is really the payoff of two seasons of
Aria training to be this this faceless
man later we get to pay off with the
night king obviously and that's for her
fighting ability basically but the spy
stuff that she's been working on I wish
you'd come back after this actually yeah
but really this is it and so I think I
yeah I thought this was a great moment I
do think though I'm gonna stand by kind
of what I was saying where I started to
notice subtle things happening in the
writing the season before this mm-hmm
but yeah this season is now fully
embracing the the D&D version of the
story and it did start to get a little
bit more spectacle based a little bit
more what makes good TV yeah and I think
unfortunately while the writers may have
intended this some being the last time
Arya would use a famous person's face to
orchestrate this assassination I think
there was some mismanagement of
expectations there because after this I
mean people like us we're doing Theory
videos online everyone was wondering who
next who Arya would use what she used
Jamie's face which see where the night
Kings face to go kill Cersei or you know
James face to go kill Cersei so I think
there was some kind of mismatch of
expectations and I think we were seeing
and many of us were pointing this out
season seven and eight it was more about
like rushing to get to the next big
moment and pay off and to kind of close
the book and close the chapter rather
than just like living in the character's
world for a second but I feel like in
season eight we got one great moment of
that which what came in Episode two and
90 the Seven Kingdoms when Jaime
knighted Brienne this picture looks like
he's chopping her head and slowly
slicing across their faces like yeah
yeah but this is the moment where Jaime
and Brienne s platonic relationship
reaches its emotional climax by
anointing Brienne and this I think my
favorite part of it not only does he
give her something she deserves that she
is
more than any other character Jaime and
away is kind of renewing his own vows
and repairing the damage to his honor
that he did by becoming the Kingslayer
by the crimes he committed against bran
by all the bad things he's done in the
show
Jaime's trying to find redemption in
that moment by passing the torch on
someone else to me this should have been
the equivalent of their sex scene yes
this I enjoyed this a thousand times
more but and not because I you know I'm
jealous of who but because I thought
this was where the emotional climax of
their story was and it felt like it
needed to be here and this was also you
know this is why I without Brienne was
gonna die mm-hmm she had kind of
completed a bit of a journey there but I
mean this true real tears you know this
was the shirt and this was a appropriate
payoff to something that been coming for
so long which is why I felt like the sex
scene was unnecessary yeah I agree and
it's cool because if you think about it
by returning to Winterfell Jaime brings
back the other half of Ned Stark's old
sword so his sword is the one he got
from Joffrey after Joffrey died he gave
his original sword to Brienne Oathkeeper
so now the twin swords that were melted
down from Ned Stark's sword are kind of
reunified and reforged in a way and I
think in a way Ned Stark's legacy his
spirit is kind of overseeing the honor
of this moment so Ned Stark it kind of
comes full circle with Ned bearing his
sword in the first episode so not to say
everything that came after that in
season eight was bad I just think this
is the last great character moment with
really really good writing that made us
feel like this is the same show that was
there in season one but we want to know
what you guys think are there ones that
we didn't mention in this episode
clearly they were yeah oh that was great
it's so much like good comedy writing
that happened on the show and like good
moments that were just really well
adapted from the books so we're not
saying the red wedding wasn't worthy of
mentioning of course red wedding is
great of course Ned Stark's execution is
great there's lots of great things that
happen on the show but I think the
writers who are working on this really
show that they're capable of not needing
George RR Martin's exact dialogue and
kind of create great character moments
the character moments are
you know a lot of people think that
that's that was their downfall I
actually think it was because they went
through they actually focus more on
character than they did on world arc
yeah
which what they've been going through
initially so they definitely do actually
know what they're doing with character I
I just gotta wonder maybe if they'd
started in charge of the character arcs
and then it maybe wouldn't have felt
jarring perhaps but let us know in the
comments down below what your favorite
moment was maybe that we mentioned one
that we missed and keep make sure that
you're subscribed to new rock stars and
subscribe to our podcast feed Westeros
weekly wherever you get your podcasts
and stay tuned for more interesting
podcast content that we'll all be having
soon yeah make sure to hit me up on
twitter i chat with you all in on there
it's at fimo and you can also hit me up
on Instagram at Phillip Malina I'll chat
with you there too yeah and you can
follow me on instagram or twitter at
Avis thanks for joining us thank you for
joining us they thanked us for joining
what we